la decisión del juez Federal de Texas
que prohibió el uso de la píldora
abortiva mifepristona aprobada hace 20
años por la administración de drogas y
alimentos de Estados Unidos conocida
también como la fda biden condenó la
decisión del juez distrital
tiene fue designado por Donald Trump
afirmando que la corte sustituyó la
decisión de la agencia experta en
aprobar las drogas en Estados Unidos con
el criterio de un juez y dijo que si
esta decisión se mantiene después de ser
apelada se abre una caja de Pandora para
cuestionar otros procesos de la fda Y
hacer que las prescripciones aprobadas
por la agencia sean foco de ataques
políticos e ideológicos biden agregó que
este fallo es otro paso sin precedentes
para quitarle las libertades básicas a
las mujeres y poner en riesgo su salud
respecto del fiscal general dijo que la
decisión a Luna una posición experta y
una aprobación experta de la fda dictada
hace más de dos décadas de que la
mifepristona Es segura y eficaz de
mantenerse este fallo las píldoras para
el aborto serían prohibidas en todo el
país Incluso en estados donde es
permitido el aborto expertos legales
dicen Además que lo más probable es que
esta decisión termine en manos de la
Corte Suprema de Justicia de mayoría
conservadora cabe mencionar también que
más de la mitad de los abortos en
Estados Unidos se realizan con
medicamentos en lugar de cirugías